new 14 and 16 inch MacBook Pros with the
new M2 Pro and M2 Max chips have finally
been revealed through a press release
and not only that but the Mac Mini has
also just been updated with M2 and M2
Pro chip options finally replacing the
old Intel model so in this video I'm
gonna go through all of the new details
and give you guys my own recommendations
on whether it's worth actually upgrading
to any of them right now or waiting for
the M3 chip family models so let's get
right into it now of course with the new
Macbook Pros we have the same 14 and 16
inch models with the M2 Pro and M2 Max
upgraded chips those are five nanometer
chips from tsmc unfortunately we did not
get an upgrade to the four nanometer
which definitely sucks it finally got
upgraded to up to 96 gigs of RAM which
is absolutely insane I do not recommend
that the common person goes that high it
is over kill but a nice upgrade is that
we finally have Wi-Fi 6E that is nice
and Bluetooth 5.3 to match up to the
newer iPhones and airpods pro 2. as far
as the HDMI port we finally have HDMI
2.1 which is what we needed from the
very beginning thankfully with the
efficiency updates we did get an
improvement for the battery life we have
18 hours on the 14 inch and 22 hours on
the 16 inch which is one extra hour each
for video playback which honestly isn't
that much if it was on three nanometer
it would have been a lot better but it
looks like we have to wait for the three
nanometer M3 Pro and M3 Max chips in
about a year and a half and as far as
the storage we have the same eight
terabyte storage limit just like we had
before but in terms of everything else
like the design it's basically identical
it looks the same the same shape same
every everything same displays no
difference there it's basically the same
with the ports everything else it's a
little bit disappointing but thankfully
the price is the same two thousand
dollars for the 14 inch and 2500 for the
16 inch so it's nice that it's at least
the same price and you get those
upgraded specs and chips and now let's
move on to the Mac Mini which hasn't
been updated in Forever literally the M1
Mac Mini in November of 2020 was the
last Mac Mini update and people have
been waiting so long for the M2 version
but now it gets even better because you
can either get the M2 Chip or the M2 Pro
which is a lot of performance packed
into the Mac Mini but other than that
not much has changed we have the same
design the same exact chassis basically
the same ports with two Thunderbolt
ports for the M2 Chip it model and four
of them on the M2 pro model and that is
replacing the Intel model finally I
don't even know why Apple was selling it
probably because they needed to have a
four port model for those who wanted it
now as far as the M2 Chip base model Mac
Mini you have between 8 to 24 gigs of
RAM between 256 and 2 terabytes of
storage but the craziest thing is the
pricing the new M2 Mac Mini is only
599 a hundred dollars cheaper than the
M1 model and you can get it as low as
4.99 with the educational discount that
is absolutely insane they're gonna kill
the low end PC market now the real
Banger is the M2 Pro Mac Mini and that
one gets a lot more performance finally
in a Mac Mini and of course the cooling
should be just fine because I don't know
if you know this or not but the M1 model
it barely used half of the internal
space of the Mac Mini so it's going to
be just fine with the M2 Pro chip now
this one can go up to eight terabytes of
storage which is a ton in that little
Mac Mini machine you now have four
Thunderbolt ports and basically it has
the same specs and features as the M2
Pro MacBook Pro and all those options
are basically the same and as far as the
pricing we have
1299 which is an absolutely killer deal
for getting an M2 Pro chip because the
only other way you're getting that is if
you're paying the two thousand dollar
price tag for the 14 inch model so for
only thirteen hundred dollars that is a
ton of performance so overall the
updates that we got today are pretty
basic which is why it's a press release
with basically nothing changing in terms
of the designs or the display features
on the MacBook Pros and even the ports
are basically unchanged just getting
small up updates but in terms of if you
should upgrade or not here is my honest
opinion I actually own a 16 inch M1 Max
MacBook Pro right now at home and I'm
definitely not going to upgrade because
the main thing that matters to me is the
design the display the feature set all
of that and obviously it hasn't really
changed at all and in terms of the
performance mine already handles
everything that I can throw at it photo
editing video editing everything else
it's just fine so I don't really see a
point in upgrading just for the faster
chips and since the battery life has
barely improved even that aspect of it
isn't really a big deal so in my opinion
nobody that owns an M1 Pro or Max
MacBook Pro should be upgrading now the
biggest issue in terms of upgrading to
these machines is that the new M2 Pro
and M2 Max are still on second gen 5
nanometer and the previous versions the
14 inch with the M1 Max overheated and
thermal throttled so much so that the
high-end 14 inch was slower than the
lower end 16 inch in some tasks that was
embarrassing and now it's gonna be even
worse with the new M2 Max 14 inch so
keep that in mind and wait until we do
our testing now if you skipped out on
all of the Apple silicon MacBooks then
that definitely changes things and if
you're ready to purchase now then
definitely do it as these are upgraded
with modern specs however if you can
wait another year and a half and be just
fine with your current MacBook or even
if you wait until the end of the year
for the regular M3 MacBook Air then I
would honestly wait because the M3
family of chips will be a lot better in
terms of efficiency and performance
thanks to three nanometer chips from
tsmc now as far as the Mac Mini that new
M2 pro model is an absolutely killer
deal in terms of performance and value
and it could even be worth upgrading
from the M1 Mac Mini if you have that
right now and definitely from any intel
model this thing is honestly the best
bang for the buck map you can get with
high performance and I would even
recommend this over the Max studio for a
lot of people out there because of the
crazy good price so there you guys have
it hopefully you enjoyed this video and
let me know down in the comments what
you think about today's announcements
from Apple and if you want to get a
better deal on the M1 Pro 14 inch right
now instead of waiting you can use the
YouTube tagging feature to check it out
and click that Circle above to subscribe
for more videos like this one especially
when we start benchmarking these new
Macs thanks for watching and we'll see
you in the next video
foreign